ladies and gentlemen I'm Greg Albert I
have seen the movie Aquaman and I'm by
myself today because John is actually
out of town for a while
he'll be back tours Anna this week so
you got just me today now before I hop
right into my review I just wanted to
tell you guys download and follow us on
the Stardust app over there we do 30
second reaction reviews for any film TV
show or trick
you know I've shot them out plenty of
times you guys know who they are what I
really want to tell you guys today is to
go to Subway get an Italian meatball sub
here's how you're supposed to get it you
get the bread buttery garlic on it a
bunch of mozzarella cheese and then you
toast it then you put the turkey
meatball marinara on it and you get some
Parmesan cheese I like to add olive oil
and vinegar if you don't I totally get
it but this is a limited-time sub I
really hope that if enough people buy it
they keep it throughout the year they
are not paying me to say this seriously
I just really hope that by 2019 they
announce that this is an official new
Subway sandwich that's my sponsorship
today that's not paid for anyway on
Aquaman Aquaman is a movie directed by
James Wan it stars Jason Momoa
as Arthur curry and it is the story of
how Aquaman learns that he is heir to
the underwater Kingdom Atlantis and must
step forward to lead his people and
become the hero he was destined to be
I'm Chris Tuchman I know a lot of people
really like this movie a lot people love
this movie and then I've heard some
people who don't like it some even like
hate this film but it would appear that
majority of people really dig this film
I dig it and for you guys who know me
I'm by no means a DC hater
I love Wonder Woman that's what
everyone's go-to answer is but I do love
Wonder Woman and I made a whole video
called why I love Justice League I like
Man of Steel the other two films and in
this specific flick there are plenty of
great things Jason Momoa as Aquaman his
charm and energy really makes for great
leading man territory and you could tell
this bro loves being a part of this
journey and he is freaking cool as ice
water oh god I hope I don't make too
many of these jokes seeing him in action
is bad he gets to demonstrate this level
of wit and depth that I don't recall
seeing in any of his other prior body of
work like how everyone else has already
said the visual effects in this film are
astounding I did not see this on IMAX I
I already have tickets to go watch it in
a few days on IMAX cuz that's the way
it's meant to be seen apparently but as
it stands now the effects are nothing
short of incredible other times that it
looks super cgi that you're aware that
it's CGI yeah of course of course it
does but I'm not really gonna criticize
the film for that because for the most
part I really believe the whole world
this is like a near impossible task and
the fact that they pulled this much off
wordplay 80% of the movie a CGI it's
amazing and yeah there are awesome
awesome
action scenes in this movie it's truly
at its best when there's action taking
place James Wan really knows how to do
some incredible tracking shots whether
it's exploring the numerous territories
of the the hidden underwater worlds or
many of its epic action scenes there's
this kinetic yet smooth approach he has
to the action which makes for truly
enticing sequences funny enough my
favorite action scene is actually very
early on with Nicole Kidman's character
at Queen atlanna it's not the biggest
one it's not the longest one which is
what most women have told me but it was
my personal favorite action scene and
all the other action scenes ever teased
in the trailer are directed wonderfully
the fights with Aquaman and arm the
rooftop chase scene through Italy fight
scenes of Black Manta the big climactic
battle in the end it's all great and the
whole cast is really good too often
times you get these films that have so
much green screen actors can kind of
feel rather bland in their performance
but you really felt the depth out of
each performer in this movie I liked
amber hurt as mera mera I'm not sure how
you say it they kind of seem to hop
around how you say it in the movie she
get some truly badass things to do I
really like her personality and she's a
great support for Aquaman to her and
Jason Momoa have electrifying chemistry
no but it was fine it did its job
Patrick Wilson as armed was a cool
antagonist you were this fine line of
pure villain to antagonist you you
understand just because he has a
different perspective and his
personality is so different from Jason
Momoa is that it makes for a cool stand
off and it's through his character that
you get these environmental messages
which I thought was in ruin quite nicely
it didn't feel in my face or a force to
subject to keep this movie more layers
it made sense for a strong motivation
for why the people who live under the
sea
want to rise above the surface and take
control
it was very understandable motivation so
inner woman nicely for me the character
that really stole the show was actually
Nicole Kidman's Queen atlanna she had
this unspoken level of depth that I just
gravitated towards and the movie in a
lot of ways feels like it's really about
the journey of Queen Atlanta and to move
to Mira to MU I don't know how to say it
someone correct me in the comments
Tamura morrison as Tom curry the scenes
showcasing how they met their journey
are the most emotionally gripping you
got cool actors in here like Dolph
Lundgren he's only got a little bit of
screen time but he's effective when he's
there and Willem Dafoe has more screen
time than I expected and he's really
effective when he's there I didn't walk
away feeling like any actor half-assed
it just so they could get that big fat
ass comic book paycheck also the score
in this movie is great it has an 80s
synth like score that you hear in a lot
of movies which does blend well with a
lot of this really crazy adventure
you're going on and sometimes there's
like a soundtrack choice not the score
but a soundtrack but doesn't quite fit
but the composed music is wonderful and
a lot of this movie is just really fun
cheese like I don't think cheesy or
corny always means bad I think Justice
League has a lot of cheese but I love
that movie and even though the music
feels very 80s life a lot of its action
moments especially early on or like a
90s action movie which is really fun to
watch you gotta get this like
melodramatic acting it's tough it's
pretty funny and sometimes the film is
intentionally really funny jokes don't
really land but that's usually the case
with these kinds of movies so it's not a
big deal and here's what I'll say at the
end of the day when you watch the
trailers for this film the film the
final product pretty much gave me
everything I want it's a fantastic
visual feast that truly explores even
more than I expected a fully realized
world unlike anything I've ever seen
Jason Momoa is excellent and I'm happy
he's Aquaman the action is also very
unique and super fun to watch so because
it ultimately gave me all the things I
was expecting or looking for I
definitely recommend it I'd recommend
this movie alone just based off action
and visuals that right there is worth
the price of admission
however it's not to say there are things
I didn't like and those are actually
very few things I don't like if anything
there's a lot of things that I don't
think are bad I'm just sort of
emotionless towards so if anything I'm
confused on how I feel which is why I'm
gonna go watch it a sec
because sometimes when I watch a movie
like this a second time I'm more clear
about how I feel the funny thing about
reviews on YouTube is that people take
them as finite opinions but you know
what else is funny feelings are subject
to change for example I like Suicide
Squad the first time I saw it the second
time I saw it
I did it and I liked Justice League the
first time I saw it the second time I
watched it I loved it and I'll say this
the more I think about the movie the
more I gravitate towards it in a
positive direction but at the end of the
day there's no defusing of any bomb here
that I can actually do that would
prevent the toxicity of fan boy and girl
comments coming in most I can do is be
honest and JumpShip so when it comes
down to the question of do I love or
hate this film my answer is neither i
weirdly just feel like it's fine it does
what I expected the thing is I never
quite felt emotionally attached to a lot
of what was happening that's what makes
me confused cuz this is not by any
stretch
a lazy movie or a film that's void of
emotion there's so much emotion I just
personally as a viewer was never quite
emotionally drawn to anything that was
happening on screen even though the
ingredients to make an audience care
were technically all there the film
covers a lot a lot of things how Queen
Atlanta met Tom curry
Arthur learning his unique skills and
powers black man his motivation for
wanting to take down Aquaman black man
are going after Aquaman everything going
on in Atlantis and the other underworld
areas how Arthur feels about the people
of Atlantis so many different character
motivations and personal feelings on the
plot and the movie always makes the
effort to give extra depth to everything
that's being presented and in the first
half of the film I was kind of worried
we were doing too much because it's kind
of got this weird structure at first
this film is loaded with exposition upon
exposition a lot of plot which is common
in these kind of movies and whenever
they start explaining the history of
something which they do often the film
cuts away to show you it while talking
about it they say in films show don't
tell but this film does a lot of showing
you and a lot of telling you
simultaneously nothing's really left to
be a mystery in this movie they kind of
lay it all out all the time and I guess
one of my criticisms is it could have
put its puzzle pieces together a little
bit better in the first half especially
because whenever it kept cutting to a
new scene it would often feel like the
the tone is changing it's like every
scene was really thought out but
sometimes putting those scenes
back-to-back didn't tonally transition
too well with this
prior sometimes it really worked like
the change of tones and then sometimes
it did it sometimes it made it more
engaging and sometimes it made it feel a
little clunky I think the saving grace
for the film is that its main goal is
just to have a really fun time with the
audience so a lot of this is easy to
forgive and because of the immediacy of
the giant situation at hand you get a
lot of heavy plot moving forward scenes
when the scenes that connected with me
the most that scenes that really made me
feel something were the few scenes that
were just character moments for example
before arm and Aquaman have this Ring of
Fire battle with their Trident they have
this exchange of dialogue about how they
felt towards one another when they were
kids but it's and it's not a giant
spectacle scene but I was gripped in
that moment there's also this very short
scene where Arthur is bonding with his
father at a bar and I like that moment
it was those scenes where you're just
with the characters and I could have
used a little bit more of that because
sometimes there's character scenes that
feel like when you throw there's a bit
of dialogue in here don't we so it can
feel like internal character exposition
sort of like a CW show instead of just
being with them does I mean the script
overall it's generic it's cliche and
some of it's very a lot of it is very
cheesy dialogue but if you watch my
reactions for the trailers you'll know I
didn't really care if it did that
because I'll reiterate this story wasn't
lazy at all it's decently structured and
the movie is long cuz there's a lot of
story to cover and they do go out of
their way to tie it all up which I
really appreciate there's no loose ends
other than you know intentional
cliffhangers and it's script is
constantly elevated by its world its
direction its performances it's all the
technical stuff is yeah the script
itself isn't great this story is better
than the script if that makes any sense
my one real hard core issue with this
script like my real issue with it is
this whole movie keeps telling me Arthur
needs to be the king of Atlantis he
needs to be the king and yes there's you
know technical rules like he's the
firstborn and arm is pretty much a dick
but the film never gave me that one
scene where I go as a viewer
that's why Arthur should be king look at
his king like attitude and leadership or
whatever no the only thing this movie
gave me was a bunch of people telling me
he should be king if that's the main end
goal of it you got to give me something
more than just telling me he has to be
king I need to feel that and for a film
that shows and tells you
a lot I'm surprised it in give me that
one moment and if you completely
disagree with me on it like if the movie
has some strong examples as to why in
terms of internal character of why he
should be king then please leave it in
the comments my real main viewing
experience overall is what I said
earlier
I really wasn't emotionally gravitated
towards a lot of what was happening cuz
the movie goes from 0 to 100 in terms of
energy very early on so after a while
this is two hours of 20 minutes after a
while the fun isn't really felt for me
it's hard to feel that 100% energy for
two hours and 20 minutes and it's not
like that energy vanish in the last half
as when that issue started becoming more
apparent for me but it was sort of dip
in and out of feeling the energy dip in
and out women and I think it might be
because there's so much story that my
heart just never had enough time to
settle on anything emotionally like I'm
loses right there it was right there I'm
not to feel the night but I didn't I
could already hear the comments you
didn't have this problem with Marvel
Civil War what about infinity war the
thing that I keep in mind is this movie
is it is an introduction to a world and
a bunch of characters and like a very
little reintroduction mainly this is all
brand new stuff which makes her a very
different viewing experience I'm
conflicted about how I feel of what they
did with Black Manta in this film I
really liked that they gave time to
flush him out I liked her they gave him
real motive and you get to spend time
with him and the actor whose name I know
I'm gonna get wrong he really gives a
dissolve but ultimately in the end for
as much screentime as he got in this
movie he didn't feel entirely necessary
for this specific story he's treated as
you know like as a setup for a future
movie which is cool and his action
scenes not gonna be wrong are great but
under time he's just an action scene
obstacle in the way of the main journey
which is not bad i over all enjoyed it
it just made me wonder that they cut
back on some Black Manta moments
dedicated that amount of screen time to
more emotional moments towards the main
story of the characters would the
emotional beats have hit home a little
harder so that's some of the obvious
things of Jason Momoa being great the
visuals the action the score all the
technical stuff it's really the
storytelling elements I'm just sort of
neutral on but these filmmakers put a
lot of blood sweat and tears into making
this movie and it shows and they did put
a lot of work into their story which is
why I'm rather
puzzled as to why ultimately just ended
up feeling like it's fine in all
sincerity though seriously I would
recommend it I think majority of people
really dig this film which is so cool to
hear I really want this film to succeed
I want audiences to love it I want it to
be a box-office hit and I want a sequel
I really do it's very ambitious and I
imagined it was a very daunting task for
the filmmakers and actors involved I do
think that once the sequel is greenlit
that James Wan should direct the sequel
and I feel like he'd be able to tell an
even stronger story because now that
he's got his feet wet with all the
technical stuff he could put more
attention to telling a more emotionally
gripping tale I imagine when you're
dealing with a world like this I imagine
it's a lot of people's first time trying
to bring something like this together
that there's gonna be some bumps along
the way I think with a sequel same crew
same director same cast you can make
something hit something even better as
for now it's a really good part one
everything's there just the story
elements need to hit the feels a little
bit harder but yeah I enjoyed it I hope
people continue to love this movie I
hope it continues to kill it at the box
office I know that because I did not
suck the deal of this film I'm still
gonna get a lot of crap even though I'm
recommending it that's okay follow me on
the Stardust app cuz I'm gonna post my
opinion of it after my second viewing
check out my opinion on the Stardust app
to see if I went from liking it to
really liking it or if I like it less
let's find out anyway guys you see
Aquaman what did you think about it you
guys can comment below you can subscribe
to the reject nation click that
notification Bell you can download false
in the star dose app but more
importantly go to Subway get that turkey
Italian meatball sub immediately